but don't you think the women need to
level up I mean how many women I'm
leveled
what percent of women have cookbooks
what percent of women are Homemakers
what percent of women really work with
kids and can be good Mothers
go ahead you've had to find your
percentage you have to find your person
to find it there's women out there you
just have to find yeah but is it common
but that's for a certain type of man
there are some men that like boss babes
who have businesses
there are 100
they're broke man
so you don't think men like women that
are boss baby man don't give a
about our money because they literally
don't care it's like it's like okay I
have a guy I ever told you about a shoe
collection and you're like oh that's
cool but you don't really care that's
how men view our money they don't care
it's nothing to them but you you proved
the point what you said just now though
because you what you're saying is that
you could walk out theoretic you know
hypothetically you could walk out and
get some guy maybe come and chat you up
or whatever but you're looking for a
certain percentile of guy yeah so you're
you're basically saying oh the the you
know this group of guys who might hit on
me randomly in in West London I don't
care about them because I want this this
top tier and that's the thing that's and
I'm not saying that's a bad I mean
that's absolutely your everyone's
prerogative but at the same time I think
a lot of guys are finding it
increasingly difficult in this in this
dating Marketplace you know because
women are The Gatekeepers basically you
know yes so I'm curious um because I
hear this a lot like I'm not gonna get a
guy that's not on my level or is that
what you said I don't want to miss
quotes yeah I just don't want to be of a
guy that's just not up to the standard
that I that I want so when as women do
we lower our standards and decide that
they're too high if we don't if all the
guys we're talking to don't live up to
the standards that we want when do we
lower them when you're getting old and
there's no more
but your body clock is given up and you
can't have children so 90 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30. so at what age
would you say that women should start
lowering their standards because I like
to be 30 then if that's the case because
I need children do you know what I mean
because it's geriatric pregnancy starts
at 35. wow so I think a lot of times
like women we think our biological clock
is a lot longer than it really is you
freeze your eggs that's also an option
yeah yeah but
um I I can't remember the stat off the
top of my head but it doesn't work out
for a lot of women they kind of sell us
that dream yeah
um I wish I could remember what percent
of women actually get pregnant but it's
not as high as you think
after geriatric pregnancy yeah I think
the other way round it's only about 50
if a guy freezes his
sperm oh wow um it's quite it's you know
it's like a 50 50 shot basically whether
it's gonna it's gonna work or not
I mean yeah it's a bit of a tricky one I
mean
yeah
I don't know
under
but no one could help who they're
attracted to I mean exactly you can't
say to somebody what well you know it's
very hard to say to somebody look you
should lower your standards
um because we are attracted to who we're
attracted to and that's just that's just
the reality of it isn't it I'm curious
would you guys rather be like so at 60
65 would you rather be by yourself or be
with someone you're not attracted to be
by myself be by myself yeah yeah
[Laughter]
because to me it's like I'd rather be
with someone I'm not attracted to than
not have children
I would feel like my life was like a
failure if I didn't have kids
it is not what if it's real it's not
what were you gonna say you definitely
want kids yeah
I know so I'm asking a few of the two
options and you would still pick by
yourself you said at 65.
you just told me the age of 35 so no but
I'm saying so in one scenario at 65 you
have a husband you're not attracted to
and children and a family and then the
other one you're by yourself so I'm
saying like as women we keep saying we
need our standards to be on a certain
level right and I hear this is super
common it's not just you so it's like
but when do we start lowering them if
the men are meeting them
because what's our other option
bye dog
to tell you that
um
I think that's where it goes with the
Beauty Beyond the eye you see you start
here now you find it you don't find him
attractive first and you really start
liking him after but you see what I'm
saying when I say that like I think that
women and men have higher beauty
standards than women
like that they have to live up to
because it's such a small percentage of
men that we're even attracted to
everyone here said they're picky but
don't you feel like it happened to us
first as women we had to level ourselves
up to be a certain way when do you think
we'd level ourselves up
I'd say about 20 30 years ago
I feel like we've gotten worse in the
last 20 to 30 years see so about 20 30
years no but I don't think we've leveled
up I think women have leveled down
oh yeah but I don't agree with that no I
think I think you're I think you're
right but I write I think what probably
from my perspective I reckon what
happened was that there was that
pressure on women to be you know you've
got to look amazing all the time and
blokes like back in the sort of the 80s
and early 90s and stuff guys didn't
really have to make an effort you know
what I mean it was like you could have a
beer garden just like whatever football
shirt on oh yeah she's nice and you know
it's very laddy
pictures of guys from like the I saw
beach pictures from like the before the
60s everyone was hot back then I thought
there was so much more attractive I
think well and the women they were I
feel like something switched in the food
or something well maybe in maybe just in
England then but no I know what you mean
because I've seen in pictures in like
Brazilian stuff like from the 70s I've
stuck in the US like California pictures
oh really yeah okay okay okay
I don't know well I did I from my
perspective what I've seen I I think
that
standards for men have got higher in the
last 10 15 20 years that's that's just
just my sense of it and maybe women's
had to have been higher in the past but
um it like I don't know it doesn't
really help anybody does it you know
what I mean like like um I I think I
think now because of the thirstiness of
guys and the fact that as you as we've
said I mean guys are less selective than
than women I think guys are now more
less picky than they were do you know
what I mean I think I think there are
many guys who will take a woman who's
perhaps less attractive than he would
have preferred because he thinks that's
his only option I think ultimately is
finding somewhere you're compatible with
so all these standard standard standards
is like what is a standard you know if
he's a good girl he's a good girl and
it's like you know it's compatible to
you it's got the same values same you
know principles and you get along well
and you have the same you know goals in
life I think that's what can be defined
as a you know yeah I'm curious what what
are your standards
like what what do you guys look for in a
guy
the right person I think like lots of
women no because it's like you don't
look for anything
women
no because I I know that lots of women
they look at you know how much money my
man is making how much you know good
good life yeah you don't have to say
money it could be like whatever you look
like for me it's like having emotional
support most of everything and you know
having someone that you know understands
my needs you know my ornamental level
obviously you know we need to you know
do life together and navigate you know
challenges and everything but ultimately
for me is about finding that compatible
person which is very difficult to do
because you know you're gonna have
always something you know that was um
some character traits that are not
really you know men and women are just
different and as much as we want to play
this car oh I want to be like a man I'm
never going to be a man I wasn't born a
man and I'm not gonna understand what it
means so don't you think that asking him
to understand your emotional needs is
asking a man to be a woman when he's not
a woman
a little bit yes but no in a way like
don't get me wrong yes maybe a little
bit yes but at the same time I don't
want to call the person you know in
front of me no you know I want to have
someone that is kind of empathic enough
you know got a little bit doesn't sound
too hard to find a worm a nice guy
you think that's hard
um like what else there has to be yeah
yeah I mean but
um there's gonna be loads of guys in the
chat now is it I'm a nice guy I can
emotionally support you
no no I mean I mean I wanna you know I
want to say this like there are lots of
great guys out there I don't want to be
like oh yeah man it's just I find that
in this particular time that we're
living guys are like finding very
difficult in committing on the long term
because in a lot of pressure there is in
this Society so it's like I can't
provide to my woman because you know the
bills are going high you know the
society is crazy at the moment you know
and women want always more more the last
clothes the last you know Trend that is
there you know I need to satisfy that
and I feel like that it's quite
detrimental so I feel like yes you
arrive maybe we can lower a little bit
our standards and strike trying to be
more realistic with what we really you
know without how old would you date like
is there an age range like you said
you're 37 right 8 38 okay so would you
date a 21 year old guy uh no I don't
think so okay so so there's age yeah
because it's just question I mean yeah I
don't think so it has to be like you
know mature enough for me to you know
for me to get deep conversations without
like oh what are you talking about
without scaring him and I think like
when you're 21 you still need to
figuring out a lot of things I'm not
saying that by 38 you're gonna have
everything no so you did a 55 year old
guy that's okay
no I don't think so okay
you know maybe maybe up until you're 45
45 Yeah okay or less yeah anything else
so he just has to be emotionally
available under the age of 45. funny
over 30 maybe over 30. yeah but I'm not
doing like doing an artwork
um
no no no no no no there's no an advert
um just as I said like for me the
emotional support without being too much
of a woman is very important and to be
able to you know understand like that
try to understand us because as we as
women we're trying to understand men and
we're trying to get into that masculine
energy which is quite like difficult to
do and at the same time I would love you
know that the man trying to be a little
bit more empathetic and trying to
understand without becoming a woman I
mean it has to be men it has to be men
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible